bonsoir marcel kabanda merci d'être avec
nous le président macro qui a donc
reconnu à kigali aujourd'hui les
responsabilités de la france dans ce
génocide
une première réaction cette prise de
parole du président français danseur je
trouve que c'est très courageux de sa
part d'avoir dit d'avoir dix sept
paroles des rares à accepter la
responsabilité accablante de la france
et de l'avoir dit au rwanda à kigali et
au mémorial même du génocide des tutsi
là au repos de 50 mille corps donc je
trouve que de sa part c'est très
courageux
évidemment les rescapés beaucoup de
rescapés attendaient le mot excuse mais
je trouve qu'il dédie cette manière
parce que y'a pas excuses mais la
demande qu'ils demandent aux rescapés de
faire un don de pardon quand on demande
pardon c'est qu'on présente à la fois
des excuses
justement le mot excuse effectivement on
n'a pas été prononcé mais de mâcon qui
s'est justifié en estimant que
l'évocation des excuses n'étaient pas
appropriés qu'il préférait la
reconnaissance des faits est ce que vous
partagez également cette analyse je
n'aurais pas je trouve à l'est pas
indécent de sa part de prenant seulement
excuses
maintenant il a choisi les mots qui sont
les siens ce sens et c'est sur ses
parents ben je les prends je les accepte
et je trouve qu'il s'est adressé au
coeur des ce cap est au coeur des
victimes d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est
très particulier comme discours c'est un
exercice diplomatique d'état mais c'est
en discuter qui est centrée sur la
sphère des rescapés sur la mémoire et je
trouve que il a dit à sa façon ce que
j'attendais de lui
votre président rwandais paul kagamé lui
dit ces paroles avaient plus de valeur
que des excuses elle était la vérité en
éduquant comme vous le courage des
manuels micron vous êtes d'accord
c'était la vérité
skalli et le président français selon
vous aujourd'hui et il a dit la vérité
un souci qu'il reconnaît que la france
parce que je vois les mange un temps les
mots et leur hors de la france la
responsabilité politique je pense que là
il a dit la vérité
après on peut se demander si tous ces
eaux
au fond il a repris le rapport duclair
d'assaut dans ce qu'il a dit à kigali
mais la vérité c'est quand même la
reconnaissance de la souffrance des
victimes
et puis la vérité c'est ce que la france
le doigt
il a parlé de dette il a parlé de dette
donc tout ça c'est quand même la vérité
après dans les détails
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça marche je
ne sais pas si tout ça est vrai mais le
travail commence les archives se sentent
sont déclassifiés
je pense que les historiens de vos
avoirs vont pouvoir commenter vont
pouvoir réfléchir ceux ci de ses
archives et nous donner peut-être au
fond il ya un travail c'est un début qui
est prometteur pour l'avenir
réconcilier apaisé injustement discours
qu'il nature à apaiser les relations un
mac et une normalisation de ses
relations
ça en prend le bon chemin
selon vous oui parce que vous savez
c'est par là effectivement c'est pas la
première fois le président sarkozy est
allé au rwanda mais il y avait dans
cette danse est dans la démarche de
monsieur sarkozy
quelque chose et passifs et se tait il
passait sous l'avenir il voulait
construire un avenir mais ça sans avoir
500 à rayonnement éclairer le passé et
je pense que ce qui est avantageux dans
la démarche de monsieur du président
emmanuel macron c'est de nous pas c'est
de ne pas passer sous silence les faits
restent qui luttent tous les historiens
pour retrouver les éclairer mais quand
même c'est mis sur la place publique
donc je pense que là c'est une bonne
manière de passer à la page d'actualité
mais ça passait sans la lire celle du
passé je pense que c'est une bonne
manière clairement et c'est certainement
là le coeur du problème aujourd'hui de
quoi pour ceux qui n'auraient pas suivi
ce drame au rwanda de quoi la france est
elle coupable selon ses détracteurs
pendait selon les détracteurs rwandais y
avait dans votre sujet quelqu'un qui
disait que les france les fins
oui vous avez de toute façon la france
est présente au rwanda très fortement de
façon très puissante de 90 à 80 au moins
afin 93 puis revient au mois de juin 93
et la porte au gouvernement du rwanda
l'appui politique militaire financières
budgétaires
et pendant que la france apporte à ce
régime
autant d'appuis ce régime me préparant
je ne suis de ce régime commettent des
pogroms à plusieurs reprises les
massacres sont commis pendant que
d'apprendre le français les présentes au
rwanda
aux côtés de ce régime d on a entendu on
agit
dans le rapport de la commission qu'il y
a eu des alertes qui venait des rwandais
qui venaient des français des
responsables militaires français qui
était au rwanda et qui disait attention
on est là en train d'aider un régime qui
qui qui qui prépare un génocide c'est
dit c'est clairement expliqué exprimer
et la france ne peuvent pas ne pas
aucune considération de ces alertes
donc à la fin c'est comment rendre on ne
rit à monstres et après il dévore tous
ceux qui autour ça c'est une grande
responsabilité de donner les moyens de
donner la capacité d'agir à un régime
pendant que celui-ci plus papa slam à la
guerre contre la rébellion mais prépare
un massacre on à l'extermination d'une
partie de son peuple et c'est pas
acceptable après il y a 7
cette décision qui est prise par le
conseil de sécurité au moins d'avril 94
de réduire de manière drastique la la la
force des nations unies présentes au
rona la france membre du conseil de
sécurité
la pâte ne s'est pas opposé à cette
mesure par un usant de son droit de veto
tout en connaissant bien les pratiques
la nature et de ce régime tout en
n'ayant fait l'expérience de ses
capacités de ses ambitions et de celle
de sa probation a à connaître les clips
de rihanna est ce que c'est un
aveuglement mais c'est un argument il
est volontaire
c'est à dire une manière de banaliser
les crimes des massacres voir juste un
régime semble-t-il impensable qu'on va
l'aider mais il ne jamais se rendre
compte qu'au fond il ne fait pas il ne
va pas dans le sens souhaité
merci marcel kabanda d'avoir été avec
nous rappelle vous êtes ancien président
de l'association ibuka merci à vous